bonsoir jérôme blanchet g et de m 6
d'être avec nous un millier de tombes
anonymes donc découverte au canada au
cours du mois dernier et ce n'est que la
partie immergée de l'iceberg
oui sans doute comme le reportage lundi
bien c'est le début du processus donc le
gouvernement fédéral s'est engagé à
poursuivre les recherche donc c'est sûr
que compte tenu du nombre de jeunes d'un
enfant autochtone qui ont été placés par
le gouvernement fédéral au 19ème au
xxème siècle donc 150 mais quand même
qu'on peut attendre de nous découvrir
dans trois fosses d'enfants des
sépultures non identifiées donc
évidemment c'est en quelque part c'est
une tragédie c'est un deuil national
il ya un consensus au canada autour de
la volonté de fin la réconciliation
c'est le grand thème qui avait annoncé
justin trudeau
donc autant à gauche qu'à droite je vous
dirais que tout le monde est assez
d'accord pour faire ce travail
sa demande de réparation envers les
peuples autochtones alors les peuples
autochtones qui ne représente que 3% de
la population canadienne ça veut dire
qu'en gros ils ont vécu un véritable
génocide
est ce que le racisme est toujours
présent aujourd'hui une sorte de
effectivement de racisme historique moi
j'hésite à utiliser le terme systémique
parce que bon le racisme systémique on
le trouve un peu partout et nulle part
c'est un thème c'est un peu un fantôme
qui plane sur au dessus de nos sociétés
dont qu'il donne à la gauche antiraciste
abuse beaucoup de ce concept là mais moi
je parlerais personnellement plus d'une
sorte de racisme est historique c'est à
dire que il est évident à queue il y
encore des séquelles de la colonisation
il ya un traumatisme chez les
communautés indiennes qui est encore
présent aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faut parler de génocide
dont une célèbre commission d'enquêté
avaient conclu un génocide
il faut quand même préciser que les
enfants n'étaient pas assassiné dans les
pensionnats halle dont il mourrait
la grande partie de maladies etc de
mauvais traitements remarquez toute la
lumière n'est pas faite sur les
histoires mais parler de génocide c'est
quand même peut-être un peu fort là
regarde quand même il faut replacer
aussi un contexte historique
les enfants autochtones n'ont pas été
les seules personnes à vivre des abus de
la part des églises chrétiennes au
canada et des blancs aussi quand on
subit les abus sexuels étaient donc nous
allons dire que rien vous travaillez et
c'est un sujet très sensible et commet
un geste et canadiens parce que c'est
vrai que depuis la france on vous écoute
on trouve ça à peine croyable les
canadiens sont choqués de ce legs est
une vraie demande de réparations versés
ces populations tu te fais jeudi il y
avait un consensus une prise de
conscience il ya un réveil
donc ma droite là où on avait peut-être
été un peu plus insensible face au sort
des communautés autochtones
on sent qu'il ya vraiment une volonté d
un effort collectif qui va être fait
donc c'est positif
moi je suis je suis pour ça je cite il
faudrait quand même rappeler que la
colonisation et reste un processus qui
est irréversible c'est à dire que on
parle beaucoup de décoloniser le canada
mais remarquez que les canadiens
d'origine européenne ne pouvant pas
retourner en europe
donc moi je pourrai pas retourner en
france je peux pas non plus autant en
irlande parce que j'ai des ancêtres
conseil demande elle comprenait il ya
quelque chose d'irréversible dans la
colonisation on peut pas déboulonner
christophe colomb ça ne sert à rien de
le déboulonner ce qu'on peut faire c'est
réparé c'est de créer de nouveaux
aménagements concessionnels
intentionnelle pour réparer un ace que
les défaites mais on ne pourra jamais
revenir complètement en arrière sinon
c'est quelque chose d'un peu aussi topic
dans le dans cette volonté de
décolonisation cette réconciliation
cette réparation
et ce sont beaucoup de mots mais enfin
dans les faits ça donne quoi
c'est la grande question effectivement
c'est tout le monde certains coup
moralement tout le monde et pour la
réconciliation
mais le commun c'est je ne sais pas je
peux pas vraiment si c'est ça c'est la
question qui est sur toutes les lèvres
il suffira pas d'un de ses employés les
fonds publics à des communautés plus
touché l'argent ne règle pas et dont il
n'y a pas de solution miracle à se
lasser ses traumatismes
c'est peut-être un peu triste de le dire
mais c'est la vérité
donc comment vont réparer ça comment
voir réussir à se réconcilier c'est sûr
que ça vanne plus que des cérémonies des
rides suez etc
mais c'est une question à laquelle je
peux pas répondre
l'église at elle clairement une part de
responsabilité officielle est ce que le
vatican devrait s'excuser est ce que
c'est une des pistes peut-être remarqué
on multiplie les excuses sont eux aussi
dans le fait beaucoup de culpabiliser
mme illi ennemis mais aussi à seul parce
que ça devienne très manichéen le but
c'est de réparer un cp de créer
davantage de tensions entre les
personnes d'origine a béni les énergies
et c'est quand même une tendance assez
forte en amérique du nord vous savez là
les tensions raciales sont impurs et
animé en partie par la gauche - analyse
donc il fallait attendre six ans que le
pape dont doit s'excuser
je ne sais pas exactement et remarqué
que c'est pas juste l'église catholique
non plus qui est impliquée a donc
beaucoup d'églises protestantes est il
d'ailleurs les etats-unis se sont
engagés à lancer une enquête du même
genre donc par effet d'entraînement
on voit c'est un sicilien sa touche pas
je suis catholique mais 500 ça touche le
monde anglo saxon général donc le seul
cheveu
le protestantisme donc est ce que les
représentants toutes ces églises doivent
s'excuser
peut-être peut-être une partie de la
solution je ne sais pas exactement
merci jérôme blanchet gravel d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france